all else being equal this is the point
where you have the maximum opportunity
to produce
vitamin d per per day yes this is that
point
which ever more evidence suggests that
that is something that you might want to
be doing
right now given that it seems to be
protective
against coronavirus yes it's something
um
you should want to do for lots of
reasons it makes you much healthier
and less vulnerable in general but with
respect to covet 19 might be
particularly
important incidentally i ran across
something
on this front as long as we're talking
about daylight
a recent paper reflects that one of the
hypotheses that we advanced and talked
about
turns out to be right which is that one
of the reasons
that um sars cove 2 is not transmitted
outdoors as easily as indoors in fact
vastly less easy is that apparently uv
light is
highly destructive of sars cove too so
we now
know that for effect which opens the
possibility if that's the only factor
then uh it suggests that outdoors might
not be so safe at night
whereas if it's one of a couple of
factors like we've talked about the
other factor
that's probably highly relevant is
the uh air flow and the volume the
absolute volume of the air
in question so we're developing a kind
of model in which
for some reason instead of a virus being
able to get into you and infect you
there's some level at which you can
absorb these things not specifically
they're dealt with maybe by macrophages
or something and at the point you've
overwhelmed the macrophages then you are
in jeopardy and in an outdoor
environment the dissipation of these
things and if it's daytime the
destruction of them
in the sunlight makes it unlikely you
will cross that threshold whereas
indoors
it can happen in a five-minute
conversation if somebody's sick and
expelling virus towards you and i think
i think most of our intuitions
if we've spent any time in the physical
world are pretty good on this front i'm
remembering as you talked about
um i was in san antonio in november of
last year i found myself
having dinner one night an outdoor
restaurant but it was in a little alley
between two buildings
and i had been very eager to sit outside
because i always am unless
uh conditions are stifling in some
regard but because it was really
narrow between two rather tall buildings
i had the sense that the air wasn't as
fresh as i wanted it to be
and you know given what we know about
these transmissions
inside you know interior restaurants of
of the coronavirus where
people sitting it's sort of in line of
the hvac flow end up getting infected at
much higher rates than those people
outside of that
of course if you're in some kind of an
urban jungle
outside probably isn't going to be as
protective as if you're in
an outside space with a lot of airflow
as well so we've got a few of these
parameters to wrestle with absolutely
and we have indicators from history that
people have
intuited certain things sometimes
incorrectly so i believe that
both plague and malaria have been
attributed to stale air in the
historical past before the proper term
theory of disease told us what was going
on
in the case of malaria malaria is
exactly what it means
it's not really a question of air volume
it's a question of mosquitoes which
inhabit swampy kind of air
um and in the case of so they've just
got i mean it the
at a gross level at an imprecise level
the observation
is kind of accurate right like if you're
hanging out in an area with stagnant
water
that tends to produce stagnant air air
that smells of the anoxic stuff that
it's emerging from
you're more likely to have mosquitoes
around which are which are the things
that vector malaria is right it's
inaccurate but there is an observation
that's real at the base
and it's also true that in the case of
plague
which at least in the uh the majority of
cases is transmitted by fleas
you're also talking about a place if you
were in some dank place where
you know there were rats i mean rats in
particular have a smell that you
can detect walking into a room so there
is some sort of indicator in the air and
it's not that you're smelling fleas
but nonetheless it's good enough the
sense that that's maybe not a smell that
you want to hang around
is um and at some level both of them are
indicators of kind of you know trust
your nose trust your senses
yeah if if something is telling you back
off just like if you run into
a decaying you know roadkill or
a pile of feces your everything in you
says
don't get closer to that yeah those
intuitions are built around that which
of course also fits with our sense
of beauty perhaps being an indicator of
lots of proxies
for things that are useful or valuable
or tend to imply opportunity or whatever
um so anyway what a shock that we are
well designed for environments in which
our senses can detect things that clue
us into
hazards we may not be able to name or
describe and that many of us
feel more afield than maybe we even
recognize our ancestors would have
because so many of us are not even
living now in the environments in which
we grew up not only are our aphorisms
our cultural norms
built around places that most of us may
not live at the moment
but our developmental environment is not
a match for our current environment
and so we are we are we are simply
out of touch with our own selves in a
lot of ways yeah we are out of our depth
in an environment that we have
largely created